I want to show you one of the best shakes
for the liver, actually to clean the liver.
This is liver cleansing on steroids.
We have three different vegetables.
We have the kale, and by the way, I freeze
all of these vegetables, they last forever,
stick them right in the ice box, freeze them.
We got kale, we have beet tops, I cut the
tops of the beets and I freeze them.
Beet tops have 1300 milligrams of potassium
per cup.
This is 500 milligrams so it has mass amounts
of potassium, it's good for the liver, the
gallbladder, a lot of iron.
Then we have parsley, it's frozen.
The parsley is way higher in vitamin A than
the kale so it has tremendous amount of vitamin
A, magnesium, zinc, it has potassium, very,
very bitter.
All these are very bitter.
I put mainly kale, some beet tops, and parsley,
and I fill it up almost to the top with water,
but it's floating so it's kind of going over.
I'm going to blend this.
Now, here's the problem.
This is very hard to drink so we're going
to have to offset that bitterness, we have
to camouflage it with something a little bit
sweeter.
If your metabolism is slow, then you might
want to use this liquid stevia, it's berry
flavored liquid stevia.
Some people don't like the taste of stevia,
but if you do this will be a good 10 drops.
The other option is the kale shake, berry
flavored, put a scoop in there, and it won't
taste bitter anymore, it takes that bitterness
out.
This is good, but for the average person that
has an okay metabolism, or for kids and things,
you can use a little bit of berry.
I have blueberry and strawberries frozen,
I'll put those in here.
I'm going to blend this.
You can see the color is brown because you're
mixing green and red from the beets.
We're going to take that, talk about enzyme
rich.
This is what I do.
I'll down one of these and I'll do another
one in the day.
Don't drink this before you go to bed, you'll
be up peeing, it's like a diuretic, so much
potassium.
I also use, everyday, I use the Cruciferous
Food as well.
This has a spectrum of organic beets, brussel,
kale, it has cabbage, radish, garlic, tumeric,
sea kelp, so this has all organic vegetables
too, like regular vitamins are all synthetic
chemicals.
This is like a real vitamin.
Three of these a day will give you a tremendous
amount of nutrition, but it has the phytonutrient
effect.
I'll do three of these in addition to this,
so it gives you a healthy glow, it gives you
a lot of energy, mental clarity.
You wake up and you feel bright in the morning,
so definitely go ahead and start using this
combination, keep it in the freezer.
Go ahead and subscribe to my channel, and
make your comments below.
I'll see you in the next video.